brooklyn nine-nine people all i'm gonna
say is thanks to the boys of prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
roll that intro
[Music]
my mom is marrying shutter
charles's dad toilet emoji we are gonna
be brother and sister to think this
started with us just going to town on
each other's sexy parts
status update rosa how are the flowers i
don't know
yellow
[Laughter]
i don't care how many criminals go free
all right dismissed uh i'm not done with
my briefing yet i said dismissed
as those leadership skills was talking
about guys
guess who i'm about to see the boobs
jenny gildenhorn the girl who dumped you
out your bar mitzvah yes turns out
gina's mom is friends with jenny
gildenhorn's mom and jenny is gonna be
at the wedding that's right i'm finally
gonna get the slow dance that fun denied
me
her husband matt hench who she divorced
three months ago probably because he's a
major loser i mean assistant u.s
attorney get a real job we really kept
tabs on her huh it's most of what i do
here
hey
what's happening
i told amy i liked her she told me she
was deeply in love with me and it's all
in the past i did not say love or deeply
it's in the past amy move on
i'm not bringing marcus you guys broke
up huh
just hit it and quit it
only said i love you to three people my
mom my dad and my dying grandpa and one
of those i regret which one grandpa
grandpa cancer so now i look like an
idiot oh man
[Laughter]
who would be better equipped to deliver
a heartfelt emotional speech about love
i could do it mario karen
yesterday was chest and shoulders today
and for the rest of your life it's heart
and soul
i got the ring let's go okay thanks just
talking careful there
that was my informant she spotted my
counterfeiter four blocks from here we
have to go check it out i've been
chasing this guy for two years what if
it was your caller i would have caught
him nine months ago in a shootout on top
of a ferris wheel
i don't see that
he's my eddie fung
fung all right that i understand we'll
check out your lead then we'll go to the
wedding let's go find eddie fung minsk
right minsk
[Laughter]
there you go thank you
you nervous oh not at all i love darlene
linnetti with
all my parts wow can't ever imagine
being with someone and not having any
doubts i have little doubts
tiny little doubts
maybe i'm just doing the same thing over
and over again
lin boyle rushes headlong into another
mistake like that time i tried water
aerobics and i
broke my neck oh
i wonder what jenny gildenhorn will be
wearing tonight do you think she'll be
in her high school field hockey uniform
that'd be crazy right yes it'd be crazy
if that's what she wears to a wedding
yeah do it
well i hate to say it but there's no
sign of minsk we should really get going
jenny awaits oh my god look
[ __ ]
oh you're going to lose that ring man
clearly mess up your suit in the process
i love this tux on gun out i feel like
james bond and you are my mysterious
femme fatale that i've been partnered
with maxi pad
i want that bond movie
he's heading for the album
probably heard you
rosa thinks i should call at the wedding
that is not what i said this is why i
don't talk to people i just asked him if
he was feeling nervous rosa you know how
suggestible boyle men are i saw one
samuel l jackson movie and i wore a
kangol hat for three years
[Laughter]
how's that speech going do you want to
hear it yes darlene and lynn i want you
to remember the words of luther vandross
a thousand kisses from you
oh no
thousand
kisses teary terry
captain the speech is yours it needs to
be emotional and poetic can you do it
well my first captain used to call me
emily dickens
of course he meant it as an insult about
my sexuality but
i am good at
emotion
[Laughter]
the ring the ring i can't let jenny see
me like this i ripped my cumber bun it's
okay i have an extra one you could
borrow it from my high school jazz band
uniform i'm only gonna tell you this
because you were a great partner today i
played french horn
i still do
[Laughter]
play it at the wedding made it in time
oh amy your dress is filthy luckily i
brought you a spare outfit
oh my god it's jenny
she's here okay how do i look
you look great go get her bond thanks
maxie pads
jenny gildenhorn i didn't know you were
coming to this jake peralta yeah oh my
god how are you i'm good i'm good wow
hey i don't know anyone here want to sit
together uh yes i would after you
what are you doing give me the ring you
sound like gollum that means nothing
okay well not to worry i've got their
anger
it's in the dumpster that's pavements no
big deal oh god
uh huh
i lost the ring oh my god ah
i must have dropped the ring somewhere
around here during the takedown mint's
got it jake
look oh my god you found it and you're
on one knee are you proposing yes will
you jacob peralta accept this ring and
bring it with me to our weird friend's
parents wedding a thousand times yes
show us my ring
tight
are you gonna be able to get it off oh i
mean the ring is actually
ah amy it's stuck the ring is stuck we
have to get this off jenny's gonna think
i'm married also it'll ruin lynn and
darlene's wedding yeah yeah yeah it's
just us here you don't have to pretend
like you care about them
[Laughter]
i love you mom i love you
[Laughter]
no do not take off that talks lynn what
are you doing we had a deal i said if
you hurt my mother i will cut off your
son's testicles you're right
cut him off go
i'm worried i'm just rushing into this i
barely know your mom i don't even know
her favorite kind of soup is a tomato
nobody likes soup lynn
do you know who never ever rushes into
anything
cowards
that's exactly right rose invite him
and you're a weirdo i'd call you a
hobbit a human pile of mashed potatoes
but you are no coward lin boyle how do
you know what a hobbit is
that's a good point
oh you're right
it's time for a wedding
pants dad pants
wedding with pants yeah
what did the officiants say when you got
married not much
when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was going to
be struck down so speed was obvious
do you kevin yes
and do you yes yes we do
we're married
[Laughter]
i could pull the ring off but it might
hurt your little fingers that's fine i
just won't look so i don't know when
you're gonna do it
jenny
no
poor guy
we did this our sex made this happen
charles mike's on we can hear all this
bud
i'm captain raymond holt welcome
marriage is a contract but it's so much
more than that
it's
commitment
it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger it sustains you
darling
to be your lawfully wedded wife i do i
now pronounce you husband and wife you
may kiss the bride
congratulations charles marcus rosa said
you weren't coming yeah i wasn't i just
got the call about an hour ago
but hey i'm dvr and bones so no spoilers
don't worry i don't watch too scary
i didn't ask you the wedding because i
was being a coward i'm scared things
were moving too quickly but i don't give
a crap i love you
that's all i wanted to say if you had
plans tonight you get out of here
i love you too
way to go you two
nick cannon you're just
kind of a character now
you guys are in the middle of something
i'm gonna go to the car get my cds
[Music]
oh
no
come on i know it's not jenny gildenhorn
but if you wanted to slow dance tonight
i know somebody who'd be into that okay
perfect this is gina's great aunt susan
she's been asking about you all night
she thinks you're very handsome says you
have a dancer's frame well you have a
good eye m'lady shall we
dance the night away jakey that's cruel
she's very handsy
[Music]
oh
yes
that's uncomfortable
it's a little that's uncomfortable i
want to see a birdman like movie but at
a wedding
hey that's a terrific idea wow yeah
right i don't know why they haven't done
that yet just like
an hour and a half till the wedding
starts and everything's going wrong you
know one person is trying to get it
i had like a spiral of thoughts when i
was watching gino like she just killing
it this episode she was really taking
charge and really seeing that assertive
passionate really caring side about this
and having it hold it together
and then i was like it's kind of like
birdman that would be kind of cool to do
like a one-take movie about a wedding
dude you're one treatment away from
selling that idea yeah that'd be a cool
movie what a wonderful romantic thriller
take it anyone who's a writer heard that
who wants to do it take it put it out
there just know it's credible where you
heard you heard it from
the inspirational thought you come up
you come up with the characters and
everything but it sells itself based on
an original nugget by greg yeah
just get that crazy yourself
maybe i should cut this out of the video
nah it's a race to the finish line now
people yeah
you really that's a terrific idea that
is a once in a in every five years kind
of idea yeah yeah it's just uh you're
trying to keep it together yeah well
things go wrong cause we've all seen
that things of weddings going wrong just
be a different way of capturing it yeah
and then you could have like an all drum
soundtrack just like birdman yeah what's
more wedding you know it's gotta be all
bells or something yeah yeah it's gonna
be something wedding specific
great wardrobes yeah
yeah there's something in mind there
this is a really good episode
yeah reignited that chemistry love that
you we
yearn for for when it comes to
peralta
and amy
i love seeing them together out in the
field in their tux and dress
that was pleasant
those obsessions will kill you
yeah i remember like just so much to
jake i just so much of what he does i'm
like man i
i know exactly what it feels like to be
this guy like in so many ways
oh
no it's embarrassing it's embarrassing
i'm glad this character exists though
hey man yeah you gotta have that harmony
you gotta get that catharsis of uh
recognition out it was unnecessarily
over long obsessive crushes yeah that
will destroy you kind of keeps tabs on
someone for years and years until you
can finally requite the love
girl man
whatever weddings are like are people
like [ __ ] like just
it must be some type times
so i love wedding crashers
i've been to a couple weddings but i
don't see like a lot of random hookups
but i guess it happens it must have yeah
my guess i guess would be that the
bigger the wedding is the better the
opportunity for something like that
because i've only been to a couple
weddings i feel like in my life and
they've been a much smaller they've been
like very intimate
events
but uh hey you know that's the thing if
you got strangers around people are
looking to commiserate and people are
looking to
you know uh let loose a little bit in
the wake i don't know there's like a
competitive thing that happens i think
to some folks when there's like a
wedding on and so it's like oh man i
gotta get the pride they gotta yes
that's it that's the ultimate yeah
that's the conflict of your uh one of
the conflicts of your birdman movie is
someone's trying to woo the bride before
the marriage actually happens and then
the bride just wants it to actually go
off and there you go
i would like that
and so yeah i think this movie i think
this this episode was uh it was
refreshingly different throwing our
characters our ensemble into scenarios
that like knowing how to pluck i thought
we might get a little more hitchcock and
scully doing some like messed up things
yeah but they don't which is that that
could that's where like the chaos really
could have happened but i like the
character drama and the way that like
the way they utilize boyle's dad too
what's happening saying it's like such a
great actor steven root steven root um
the way they utilize steven roots like
really give him a character moment and
knowing like you know how easily uh oh
god what help me out here again john
what's the word he used uh is it easily
influenced ah the boyle men are easily
suggested digestible yeah easily
suggestible um know how easily
suggestible we are and it's like yeah
that is true that is a big part of what
makes boyle such a funny character is
how suggestible he is but then seeing
where he gets it from and just that one
question are you nervous at all and that
level of confidence that he has like now
this is the right thing but then how his
mind spirals
uh i love that i thought that was really
well done and the way they connected the
pieces throughout all this the way they
intertwined it all where you decipher
off rosa with boyle's dad and then that
eventually leads to her realizing oh no
i shouldn't be cowardly i should take a
chance and invite nick cannon a
celebrity guest star who's not a real
character she shows up for one scene
every episode i don't know what he's
doing
so
she can it can to show up here
um i thought something might arise from
gina and boyle but no that'd be kind of
creepy to happen on wedding day
uh
yeah the marriage happening and then the
way it it conspires with uh uh terry
hopefully like being nervous but then
overly sensitive to going to halt and
then having the heart come back around
with his husband when he's looking at
him like that's the answers to come from
the heart there like it was really
touching i thought the way they like
connected all these threads with the
characters was really well done
throughout
and uh the ticking clock of like peralta
having to get back in time before jenny
is
officially persuaded by another man
um yeah why would you be obsessed with
that kind of girl
uh you know it's a josie factor never
single yeah it's a jealousy factor it's
that like i don't wanna what is it about
me why why not me if she's always dating
somebody
but yeah this is true said a really nice
like living people want porn stars oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're doing
everyone all the time with a camera
corner then what would they do what
would they do i'm not good enough
that's all you do is have sex right
what's wrong with me
yeah
that's the answer
but i really like the way that this had
like a very living kind of
ensemble story you know it's like it's
all surrounding the same event and even
though you have these multiple other
plot lines going on you know sort of
concurrently with that just like the
geography of where everyone is and the
way they play with the peril because
there are certain things
that like the only kind of like obvious
beat is like okay yeah the ring is going
to get lost somehow but even that was
like a little more fun and interesting
than you would expect and like them
going off to find minsk doesn't turn
into like a huge time wasting process or
anything like that like yeah
it's funny like for you to touch on
birdman because i think this episode
does have like a really
nice and fine grip on its time and even
though you're not doing a one shot
you're not cutting to everybody all the
time there's still like a really nice
just sense of yeah this is all happening
at the same time and you can kind of
feel like the the overall sort of uh
group and and sort of tense tense energy
that comes with that
and uh yeah it's just made for like a
really yeah it felt a little different
and granted yeah like the you know
police work isn't the main part of this
episode so obviously it is different to
a degree but it did feel like it had a
different sense of momentum and pace and
and allocation of the characters and you
did have so many
you know people kind of they're like
these like waves and swells of
characters crashing into each other to
try and problem solve and everything and
and yeah it just felt like a real
wedding party trying to happen and i
think that that's
like a subtle thing but it's a really
nice thing to kind of tie the whole
episode together like it really felt
like an ensemble episode rather than an
episode with like this main character's
plot line and that main character you
know
and uh there's a lot of really sweet
moments a lot of really like funny
character comedy obviously in the way
that brooklyn nine-nine does it but when
the sweet moments come around i thought
those were were nicely tuned as well so
you know
they don't like kevin and
hold kiss though i know
i feel like uh we could have seen
something like that little make-out
session yeah you should just like do it
on the floor of the wedding right there
you know then really that'd be like
really you know
you know uh
showy way to consummate their vows
i want a really explicit brooklyn
nine-nine episode just like a tvma
don't worry they've rebooted fresh
prince yes sizzle brooklyn
ironically just making another gritty
contra in the process
just with the same actors
do it
i want it
have people watch that freshman show is
it good
i have no idea i i remember people being
like oh there's the promos out and stuff
like that but i haven't heard anything
about the actual show itself i have no
desire to watch that sure
you don't want to watch
the thing that we all love watching will
smith on but without will smith
i just feel like comparing it the whole
time yeah
yeah that's that that i feel
bad for them because they're in a tough
position
i saw the trailer
how'd you like it
did it have everything the old fresh
prince had
if it
i wonder what it would feel like if they
didn't call it fresh prince or i had no
awareness that it was fresh prince yeah
they just called it characters are not
will uncle phil jeffrey
i'm like
this is so distracting you might as well
just call it some just call it something
else he's will
yeah oh believe something damn see
that's the thing yeah it's like i don't
know how you could do that i feel like
you could maybe do a spit like a
spin-off or an adjacent story but i
don't know it's just just don't call it
fresh prince of bel-air and then when
you credit it to say based on the fresh
prince of bel-air yeah call it new new
in new york town new to bel air or
something like that it's like a gritty
drama just it's like super gritty draw
so so what if we took
those few episodes of fresh prince that
you know like
got serious and made that the show
it's
way bigger than that man it's like i
know why you were sent to your will
crime that he had back home
that's you're selling me this [ __ ]
jeffrey's like a [ __ ] a sexy ass like
suave
[Music]
i don't butler
it
was what's carlton up to
he's cool he's just cool for real he's
cool and uncle phil's not fat
he's like buff successful entrepreneur
guys
like what i'm imagining is something i
would be curious to watch one episode of
in a morbid fashion but yeah i'd be
surprised if it's good all right guys
well leave your thoughts down below
we'll catch you soon
[Music]